you racist you're racist they're all
racists it's all over the media you
heard about it right and I'm so sick and
tired of it
I wanna puke most people out there white
black brown yellow purple or whatever
are not racists and the politicians they
love to use the racism card to gain
power and support and then the media
comes in and they love to shout it from
the rooftops
because they know if they talk about
racism they will get views and it
supports their agenda but here's the
truth most of it are lies they're
poisoning our minds and most people
don't even see it especially the young
people look at all those rioters in
America most of them young people
destroying and stealing from good
hard-working citizens that are trying to
make a living for their families we
don't have a racism problem we have a
criminal problem we protect the
criminals and we blame the cops for
trying to protect us are you kidding me
you're hearing and seeing more and more
of the slogan defund the police you know
what I don't hear with all of these
calls to defund the police is a plan B
so who will you call when they defunded
dismantle police so what would happen if
we got rid of the police of all Lauren
law enforcement things would fall apart
instantly people will die if this is
implemented what is I mean really is
anybody thought this is so absurd I
can't believe we're even talking about
it we have an authority problem we have
a brainwash problem so let's check the
facts here's the key eliminating the
police does not mean eliminating
Authority there is always a thority and
all of you walking around with black
lives matter and the organization please
listen because yes of course
black lives matter of course and so do
all other lives all lives matter so
let's check the facts because the lies
are
that cops kill more blacks than white
it's a lie they also say that it's
racist attacks that's another lie they
tell you that cops are racist and must
be reined in most Americans don't agree
with that that's not the experience they
have in fact police departments are one
of the most trusted institutions in the
country we already know that the cops
are not just white cops here's the facts
in 2019 370 white people were killed by
police compared to 235 black people in
the u.s. what you thought it was the
other way around well yes because that's
what they tell you right it's a lie okay
Daniel so what about earlier what about
2000 1817 well let's look at the facts
in 2018
only 209 blacks were killed and 399
whites yes whites were almost killed two
times more than blacks let's look at
2017 475 White's
were killed and only 223 blacks were
killed so that's more than double
White's that were killed by police what
what wait a minute so why does the media
not really talk about this because it
doesn't fit in with their narrative it
doesn't fit in with their agenda got
that that's the nub of it the most
privileged are using the most desperate
to seize power
from the rest of us now here's another
interesting fact the total amount of
blacks in America are less than 15
percent and yet they commit more than
50% of the crime in the u.s. so of
course the chances that they will
encounter cops are more than the other
races right and why are most people so
quiet when a black man kills another
black man or a black man kills a white
man media why are you so quiet because
it doesn't fit in with your agenda why
are they doing this there are reasons
not the ones they tell you they tell you
it's about racism they are not seeking
racial
justise what they are seeking is total
control of the country now this is
nothing to do with color with the color
of skin but everything to do with
culture and with a fatherless society
you can do the research you can look
into it if you're a criminal
no matter your color you will probably
encounter the police and they have a
right to put you in jail and if you are
a danger to the rest of us hard-working
citizens that obey the law if you are a
danger to us then they have a right to
take you out now I'm white I'm not
racist and I need you to listen here if
80% of all whites are criminals then put
them all in jail if 80% of all blacks
are criminals then put them all in jail
the color does not matter what we choose
to do with our lives now that that
matters now for all of you who live in
America
I wish we had your police in our country
South Africa where we have over 60
murders every single day we live in
security areas where we have guards you
can't drive with your window open
because they'll hijack you you have to
have dogs in your yard we have to farm
attacks in South Africa every single day
white farmers and also black farmers are
killed they are tortured blood tortures
hot irons they are raped and killed
sometimes hacked up into pieces in front
of their family now this is where your
country is heading if you just leave
criminals to do what they want to do and
you put the blame on police and you
protect criminals
it means thugs are in charge the most
violent people have the most power you
have a huge problem when you start to
call good evil and evil good
will there be bad cops while of course
they'll be bad cops but it will be the
minority rash the cops they care about
what they're doing they care about
taking care of citizens they have pride
in their work
will there be bad cops yes
a few but it's just like society there's
bad people everywhere are all whites bad
are all the blacks bad what about Asians
Hispanics and so on no of course not
everyone is bad but there will always be
bad fruit and good fruit but what will
happen if we just leave the bad fruit if
we just leave it out there it's gonna
get worse right and he's gonna influence
the good fruit out there you don't have
a race problem we have a sinful nature
problem and it's darkness all around us
so let's all stand together and let's
fight the evil all around us the evil in
media the evil in politics and evil in
us let's stop making excuses
let's stop judging and jumping to
conclusions making assumptions let's
look at the facts all lives matter stop
calling me a white guy and start calling
me a human being let's stop looking at
colors black white purple whatever let's
stop looking at colors and let's start
to look at human beings and stop looking
at the past because you're keeping
yourself a slave in your mind you need
to let go break free work hard change
yourself because if you're not gonna do
it for you
no one is stop your excuses you in
America you've got so many opportunities
in your country why do you think so many
other people are trying to immigrate
illegally into your country to work for
next to nothing because that next and
nothing is more than they could ever
have dreamed about having in their own
country and please listen to me most
people out there still believe that all
whites are rich and they have more
opportunities than most
the other races out there it's 20 20
people stop living in the past
there are many poor whites out there I
grew up poor myself and our family
we had to work our butts off it was
ingrained into me to work hard not just
me but our Afrikaans culture all the
friends and family of my parents as I
grew up it was something that all of us
knew and they taught us if you want to
be someone someday if you want to have a
good job one day you better work for it
he's not gonna be given to you on a
platter now let's be honest here if
you're lazy you're not gonna achieve
anything in life if you just want to get
stuff for free not work for it then
you're always gonna be poor you're also
gonna be poor in mind forever if you
stay like this you will reap what you
sow and yes of course there are some
people who start off better financially
than others but that's not necessarily a
really a good thing
some rich parents are so busy with
trying to make money that they don't
give their kids enough time at home they
just give them money but not love and
then the danger is that they become
spoiled you've heard it done before
right spoiled brats and then when you
look at poor families who have love they
are blessed a lot more we have to change
our way of thinking about race money all
of it because we have a huge problem we
are focused on educating the mind a lot
more than educating the heart which is
more important think about this for a
while in universities today moral law is
being thrown out of the window they
teach that there is no truth everyone
can lift their own truth you have your
truth and I have my truth and that is
fine there is no right or wrong so let
me ask you then this professor what if
that student what if he starts to
believe you and he think man there's no
right and wrong
I can have
own truth alright I'm gonna start
killing people and he goes to the school
and he kills people you can't tell him
no because you already told him there's
no right or wrong so who are you or the
police then to tell him this is wrong
think about what you're doing you are
creating monsters like the monster who
killed a person just because that person
was standing in front of the shop that
he wanted to loot while the killer
screamed black lives matter right is
right wrong is wrong the truth never
changes only our perception of the truth
changes and in our hearts deep down we
know right from wrong
we have a humanity problem we have a sin
problem nowadays we can't even talk
about sin but all of us are sinful and
we do sinful things that are evil and
yes there are some racists out there and
that's also a sin so I want to call all
of you out there to stand up for what is
right to stand up for truth Edmund Burke
said the only thing necessary for the
triumph of evil is for good men to do
nothing so please let's clean up our
society let's love each other because
you can only overcome evil with good we
are all humans we do not choose our
color and we don't choose where we would
be born in which country but we do
choose how to live our lives choose
right